he's in his car right now matt ryan the
elusive
matt ryan deceptively quick
the second greatest running quarterback
in falcons history
matt ryan who joins us on the program
matt thanks for joining us
how did you feel about last night's
performance
you know what it was a good win for us
um particularly the way it happened i
think you know for our defense stepping
up getting a stop at the end of the game
uh you know correcting some of what has
gone on
uh early in the year for us to get that
right was uh was good so
hopefully it can springboard us and we
can play a really good second half of
the season
is your voice hoarse from last night
it's a little bit hoarse
uh a little bit of yelling a little bit
of uh just being on the field i usually
i typically lose my voice typically the
day after a game
have you ever lost it before a game no
thank god
uh you know that that would be a problem
if we did
but also you don't have to yell as loud
because there's no fans
it is it is kind of nice going on the
road uh
typically be a lot worse than this uh
but going on the road with minimum fans
now makes it a little bit easier for the
communication the cadence that kind of
stuff
uh that part of it has actually been
good how would you describe your
touchdown run last night
i liked it i i i think that was
the longest touchdown run i've had in my
career so uh for sure the best touchdown
i've had
yeah i and i i was wondering if you're a
thousand-yard rusher
and you blew past that a long time ago
you got 1300 yards
i was going to say i'm closing in on 2
000
2000 yard rusher here do you remember
when brady celebrated when he
he said i'm a thousand-yard rusher in my
career
luckily yeah he he took a little longer
to get there than i did
i feel i feel pretty good about my
accomplishment how would you recap
the first eight weeks it's been wild uh
it really has
you know i i've been you know trying to
scratch my head because i don't feel
like we're two and six you know and
uh i feel like we've been in every game
that we've played we just uh we've had
some crazy losses
and um you know that's kind of the
silver lining in it too
what i tell the guys is that you know
we're right there we've been in every
game we've played
there's no reason we can't be in every
game we're going to play the rest of the
year and see what happens
i thought you guys were a borderline
playoff team plus the extra playoff
spot i i thought you guys just had way
too much talent and
you guys have found creative ways to
lose games like
how much do you take upon yourself
you know with these fourth quarter leads
that you guys have blown i think bears
lions and of course the cowboys
yeah it's uh you know it's
it's you i think any competitor takes it
on themselves
you look at you know what you know what
you could have done differently to
to ensure the outcome and um
you know it's tough because i feel like
there's been a lot of positives i i
really do i feel like we've done a lot
of really good things and just had some
some some really strange ways to uh to
lose games and
uh it's disappointing because we could
very easily have three or four more wins
and um you know we don't so we've we've
just got to find a way to get really hot
here in the second half
yeah and if you have three more wins
then all of a sudden it's different at
the trade deadline you know people have
talked about
do they move you do they move julio
jones you know
is everybody available at the trade
deadline and i don't know if that's
still the case like how do you process
that when you hear it or read it
yeah it's i mean i've never been in this
situation before in my career uh
you know where where your name is being
tossed around but
you know i i just know that if if you're
concerned with that
um you know it takes away from you being
prepared to play last night and so
um i've always tried to you know stay
narrow focused and focus on
you know the the opponent that we're
playing that week and just dive into
that game plan
um you know but but i also i want to be
here there's there's no doubt about that
i've been here my entire career i love
this organization
and uh mr blank and and and everybody
have been
incredible to me during my time here so
you know i really want to get this thing
turned around and find a way to get a
championship here in atlanta
and just so you know in case any of this
information or whatever is said on radio
or tv got back to you
i said if they ever moved you that i
thought
the 49ers would be the ideal place so
you could
you could reunite with kyle shanahan so
i'm just saying that
that was just a gut feeling if the
falcons would happen to do that
that's where i thought you were going to
end up so
i i didn't have any information
obviously i just thought that might be
a nice landing spot for you
well i don't know you don't have to no
i i don't want to i don't want to get
you in trouble or add a quote to it or
anything because this was just
an opinion i had when i i was told three
weeks ago
hey will they look at uh trading julio
or and or you
and then i just you know started to look
at locations and i thought maybe that
would be the place if it happened so
i think they would be we were talking
about this yesterday like people forget
how
great julio jones is there's no doubt i
mean he played he played
incredible last night but um i think he
just
tied randy moss for 125 yard plus games
that he had last night he's unbelievable
there's no doubt about it
and um he's just he's such he's such a
soft-smoking quiet guy
um you know he doesn't create a lot of
issues so you don't
hear a ton about him but his production
is through the roof and
um you know people in the game know uh
he
is he's the best there is and um
historically he's one of the best of all
time
plus you got the emergence of calvin
ridley who
i was getting the feeling he might have
been neck and neck there with julio or
maybe
looking at your you know being the
number one receiver there with the
falcons
for sure he's he's definitely you know
he's a bonafide number one
uh in this league he just happens to
play to play opposite one of
one of the all-time greats and so um
hopefully he's gonna be healthy for us
he got nicked up a little bit last night
hopefully he's gonna be fine as we move
forward but
uh he's a guy who's who's definitely
breaking through and
um i think he's gonna be a great player
for a long time in this league
all right since you won last night i can
now look back on the game against the
lions
and and we have audio of you telling
todd
don't score
i mean that's a tough position he i
don't think he was trying to i think
just his pad level was low
i mean he definitely wasn't trying to
his his pad level was low it's just a
tough spot
um you know and and and
funny things happen sometimes in sports
and that that was um definitely a tough
way to win but todd's an amazing
teammate he played awesome for us last
night
and uh you know i've really enjoyed
having him here this year
yeah not many guys uh get credit for a
uh
a game losing touchdown but that's a new
stat i think that we have it's a
game-losing touchdown
yeah i don't like those
but i didn't those aren't good but
explain something to me you said
don't score get the first but you
already ha it was first and goal from
the 10. so i didn't know
like what was i missing there that you
said don't score
get the first well i think
i i only i mean i didn't see much of it
but i
it chronologically how they splice those
things
isn't necessarily always you know just
accurate so i mean that might have been
from a down and distance before i'm not
really sure
okay of the exact audio but um
but definitely uh you know just a
disappointing way to lose last couple of
weeks but
you know nice to to right the ship last
night if your kids come
home and say they want to dress up as
patrick mahomes for halloween
get out
what if they say tom brady get out
any other quarterback how about is there
any player they could dress up
that wouldn't be on the falcons you'd be
okay with no
trust me those those two uh patrick
mahomes is we're all fans of him there
there's no doubt so
i love uh both those guys they're both
amazing players
uh but you know our boys need to know
where their loyalty lies
did you did you ever dress up as an
athlete
for halloween i was uh eric lindros
one year growing up in philadelphia i
had
eric lindgross on on rollerblades it was
that was a pretty good costume for me
didn't he have a strange number wasn't
he like 77 or 87 or something like that
he had a really high number i think he
was 88 88 i think he might have been 88
yeah hey it's always great to talk to
you certainly it's a little better after
a win but uh thanks for joining us as
always matt
thanks dan i appreciate you man all
right that's matt ryan falcons
quarterback
big uh big win last night and a running
touchdown there as well